the most famous book about other
dimensions is flatland it was published
in 1884 and it follows the story of the
main character named a square who lives
in a two-dimensional world the author's
name was Edwin Abbott Abbott yes his
middle and last names were both Avid
possibly because his parents were first
cousins and both had the surname Abbott
before marriage given this it is
conceivable that he could have referred
to himself as Abbott squared or could
have even shortened it to a square I
think we can all find a piece of
ourselves in flatland and in the pursuit
of wanting to know what the universe
really is so whether you're in a square
in a flat world or an Abbott squared in
this 3D one let's keep asking questions
and diving into the dimensions of
knowledge